what yeah what round do you think this
ends in ah it's tough tough to call I
say third round
second look at if he look nervous he's
like he's regretting he I'm regretting
all that [__] I
said oh they're not h no they they can't
touch [__] about his dad his dead dad
and expect don't throw kicks don't throw
never throw that Charlie Brown kick and
look look he don't look like he get he
he don't look like a Jose Joo Leon's
coming forward though he look determined
Leon's a sad ball
are you going to throw that jab Leon you
he I wish K kicking like that is he a CO
he's a wrestler yeah very good wrestler
yeah Oregon
State look at look at Leon he cutting
off the cage he look focused he Look
Laser
focused God UFC at its highest level
nothing better yeah this is
great I don't know why damn trying K
going forward applying the pressure he's
going to have to cut his hair off pretty
soon though Le going have to sh he does
top is tough it's very LeBron James yeah
LeBron Bing at 39 you should go to
Turkey my boy cowboy went there they
paid him they pay for your flight
everything all you got to do is post it
I'm gonna get it done they would eat
definitely do they pay for everything I
want to go get [__] done they say I'm
not a candidate though really you don't
have enough in the back or that's what
they said they didn't let me grow that
for 10 10 days they want me to grow for
10 days and they get impatient I'm going
to go do it do it yeah I'm do it I'll
connect you with cowboy hook you up with
the same company they want to do it to
Brian County being little [__] about it
why is he being a [__] I don't know cuz
you got you going have to shave it all
off yeah it's fine whatever yeah just
just sucks for a little bit you're here
let me see your hair uh
Rampage nothing wrong with that they say
you don't have enough back here to give
yeah don't have yeah yeah I that's what
they said that that that that line up in
the front though is real that [__] is
stiff it's a tattoo damn it looks good
get that uh smpp baby what's that SMP
yeah it's t place in Vegas they tattoo
that's like what Bader did or what's the
guy the Boozer on the go to boozer's
haircut that's what you that's what you
look like right now hey you better not
be trolling me [__] look at
Boozer Carlos Boozer here just type in
Carlos Boozer here and you'll get
it that's
like that's not Rampage dude at all that
boy he did the Pittsburgh Steeler helmet
that boy got the bro almost spit all
what the [__] I almost almost spit all
over your [__] Studio bro you wait
why you do him like that CH why you wait
till I take a Dr No but why you wait
till I take a drink of water to show
that [__] that's [__] man you've been
flaming me this whole this whole show
man that's [__] up bro he looks like
guy like the guys on the lava level
Mario you jump on top of bro you got to
bro you got to know you got to know that
sh you got to know that [__] don't look
right bro you got that's crazy that [__]
is atrocious bro you got to know that
[__] don't spr that [__] but you gotta
know you can people can barely tell if I
don't say nothing no you're just that's
why I mean I know I know but it's how
how did you how did you know it's too
it's too perfect man [__] you but i' I'd
rather have that than
whatever whatever [__] train W was
before I can't wait you start losing
your [__] bro tell me when I'm like that
you are it's coming I see it right there
in your hairline no that's a cic I've
had that since I was a kid yeah that's
what that's yeah me too I had one and it
was like look at my [__] bro I got locks
bro this [__] funny you 40
right 40 thank you that's when I start
going ball at 42 thank you you f to go
ball brother DG standing I gotta worry
about it running my eyebrows no that bro
that's how it started you you I you
might have a shorter forehead than I
don't know we're close are you mixed
with Cherokee no no
sir it must be my my Mongolian blood the
gang is Kong the gang is Kong heavy on
the they ain't doing [__] it it's been
four minutes they ain't did [__] feeling
each other out man man [__] all that
Leon you you letting me down bro
they ain't did a goddamn thing oh
there's a little counter there by Leon
Leon just Co I tell you right now Kobe
ain't going to win this fight fighting
like this on the back foot not
pressuring not going forward not looking
for take downon Leon's waiting for him
yeah he is but he's going forward though
usually Leon's on that back foot counter
punching but now he's he's cting off the
cage it's tough cuz Kobe really doesn't
knock dudes out [__] they both lose this
round they'll give it to Leon cuz he's
the aggressive huh ref put him on the
ground ref [__] man
yeah it's a weird game plan by Colby cuz
you're you're basically giving up you're
starting 01 you you gave this round away
oh that was a great kick there was a
great kick that means The Middle's open
I don't like how col's
kicking Jim bring up DJ ked's terrible
beard that's another Boozer moment that
[__] is Leon could get get get get
caught with like one of those crazy
punches though yeah he could but Kobe's
not really a knockout type of
dude you don't got The Knockout power no
it's not his thing who you get his first
round see that's just for men right
there look at that [__] yeah sadly the
fans can't see it but God damn yeah oh
the fans can't see boozers uh here
either no why they why the fans can't
see it I don't know since we're live
it's we're just kind of like it's a
little more touchy we're just worried
why with really showing pictures from we
can we can figure it out for the next
episode oh damn ain't that a [__] I
thought they were able to see all our
[__] no yeah damn chill no it's it's not
a tight [__] man damn what the [__]
we're just worried we're going to get
like if we show something or play a
video flag yeah and then videos I get
but picture what's this this on YouTube
yeah they they tripping like they oh
YouTube super that's why I as if I can
cuss cuz I was I wasn't sure YouTube is
not on our team as far they're on us
like crazy so what about that um um that
new site yeah how how they it's kind of
it's too political like for what I do
with the fighting and the the comedy
it's tough because it's such a political
fan base I don't
know I mean now like Tucker Carlson's on
there they threw him a bag they throw
your boy at bag I'll jump on over there
man all right who you think who you
think won the first round oh won nothing
Leon I don't Kobe you just gave away a
round and he didn't really learn much
either cuz he didn't attempt any take
Downs or nothing he's going to get ready
to take him down he's going to get ready
to go for the shot he has to I see him
setting it up he's doing a pump fake
Brad's eating the [__] out of CH yeah uh
I see what he's doing this why Liam's
not doing
much Leon thinks that he's going to try
to get him to engage so he can go for
the shot yep and he's being smart about
it yeah that's why good counter there by
Kobe but Kobe has to get Leon going
backwards even though Leon's a great
counter Striker but
like why not shoot when he's coming
forward your goal he got clipped there
your goal can't be to out strike Leon
Edwards that could there's no way you
did a [__] two-year camp and the idea
is to out strike the best Striker at the
welterweight division two he hasn't Fen
two years no bro his last one was
mazal how how did the mazal go he beat
the braks off mazal there's like two 108
rounds is mazal retired now uh yeah I'm
sure he get new soon I like mazal though
love mazal my
boy this is such a terrible game plan by
Colby now he's not with at anymore he's
running his own Camp so it could be that
his coach is like yeah just out strike
him like it's a great
idea where's he from where's Co from
he's from Oregon but he fights out of
Florida and he was at at and then uh
there was an issue with him and Po and
him in
mozal damn this is actually from
California went to school at Oregon
State where the [__] is a
clovis I've never heard of Clovis
California probably like a one horse
Town yeah where's Clovis you know he
look like he from a one horse town is
that near
Fresno it's oh it's middle middle
California you born a rais here San
Francisco
yeah that says a lot about San Francisco
is tough man tough real tough tough area
your brother ever drive up there in his
van
yeah s Fran yeah visit the mom oh your
mom's still up there yeah she's still
live there so it's here fres now oh
you're right oh well you was right where
you're from up there from California
NorCal too you from NorCal yeah that's
the bay yeah that's not considered
northcal right uh Clovis is definitely
not the bay oh but you is sanc is the
Bay San Francisco Bay anything past San
fris NorCal right Northern California
yeah I went to college in NorCal yeah
where'd you go lasson what what the [__]
did you just make up a school no it's a
junior college oh lasso yeah I went to
lasso it's like the middle of nowhere
that's a one horse Town that's State TX
what the [__] that town so that town is
so small the big thing was when Richard
Simmons came to the Walmart that would
be lit he came there back in the 80s or
whatever it was a 90s I'm not that
[__] old
man God damn it the late 90s at that
probably like
99 late [__] almost 2000 this
[__] said the 80s the 80s he hey
hey have y hey have y'all know years
older listen I just got questions you
ain't CL him not one time since he been
here you scared of him but you ain't
scared of me you know you know cuz you
know I ain't going to fight I just got
questions bro I question about his
brother in the van that's not clowning
no no no no you didn't clown him at all
there's no clowning man you clowned his
brother a little bit you didn't clown
him at all what youve been setting him
up though you set him up yeah you set me
up you set me up with these I can't
believe I can't believe you I didn't
know man it's Richard Simmons he was
popular in the
80s right yeah but did he die I don't
know if he died he died right let me see
or am I thinking of PeeWee Herman pee
Herman definely died yeah but I'm pretty
sure Rich Sherman's died Richard Simmons
right yeah uh no he's still alive 75
years old oh God damn you think he's
still working out with he tried picking
me up day I moved to LA he probably
still pulled up in a Land Rover was like
hey are you serious swear on my life
swear to God I believe it real talk I
was like damn that's rich Simmons I we
jumped in had a good time no just
kidding I was like what the [__] and I
ran the other way real talk he tried to
pick you up swear on my life swear on my
kids he asked you for your phone number
no he was just like hey where you going
I I I was new to La I was walking down
weo mhm I was at a a corn fresh corn
Grill came out of there you got be I
swear to God I was in some short jean
shorts why you was in
some because I like to party and I was I
ate my meal I was walking out on uh West
Hollywood and he tried picking me up in
a land R West Hollywood west I I didn't
know that was the I like there's
rainbows everywhere this is you walking
down West holwood some booty shorts on
yeah and you surprised that rich Sim
trying to pick you up I was in the
UFC y nothing's happening well Kobe's
he's not a great Striker and he's
decided to make this a striking contest
like wrestle bro Trump's going to be so
Trump's going to hit him you think he
just know how to get in there or what he
hasn't even attempted who knows so he's
down two nothing now his coach are like
hey bro you're not here to [__] slap
box I'm such a big fan of trump I I
wonder if if if uh Leon win Will trump
put the bet on him no not a chance cuz
Trump Is So Pro American yes you think
Trump's gonna win I hope he wins Trump
loves this country who else is goingon
to win this the other can't run no no
there's a new kid I've been seeing on
there he's he looks like he's Indian
Indian oh you talking about
re yeah he he seem like he knows a lot
he he has no background in politics
though not that you need it but he back
Donald Trump didn't but he look he
telling the truth and he knows he sounds
like he knows what you're talking about
I don't know anything about politics
there's no one that's going to be Trump
they just got to like he's so high up in
the Democrat it's a oneman race but
they're just going to try and stop it
try he is so hated he is so hated but
listen I think a lot more people see
that he was telling the truth about the
stuff he was saying agree and I think a
lot more people are coming back to
liking him but he's still so hated I
don't know why and the Democrats throw
everything hoping something sticks and
get but dude he could still be voted in
as president and then uh get himself out
of prison he oh [__]
Tri that was a yeah Kobe looks a little
old I bet you co if Kobe loses I don't
see him uh going back down the queue and
fighting for the like young prospects I
bet retires Kobe is getting his ass kick
keep kicking that leg look at that leg
you see it getting red there you go
these guys are talking about the same
thing baffling performance by Kobe's
just striking with with Leon Edwards now
he might be older and the knees aren't
the same so he can't he can't shoot the
takedown he's not setting it up good oh
he should have shot after those too
yeah would you get a king-sized bag of
those chips or dude I'm sorry they're so
good I didn't think you it's been it's
been 30 minutes of
chewing he's destroying those things
they are tasty they're so good my coach
said it's better to just fast than eat
[__] well your coach takes steroids
so
he lies to you about you believe it just
like it is what it is it is what it is
he's still in great shape looks awesome
my coach is not on steroids yeah he's
not if he say he's not I believe I don't
steroid why would everyone lie about
that ever yeah I I why would he have to
lie about it though he's he's not like
in a public eye he's not famous or
nothing like that he don't care yeah
he's not trying to be on Instagram no he
just he just you know you know why he
got you know why he got so many
followers cuz he's Persian people don't
know that he looks white he's Persian oh
yeah he looks white as [__] yeah he's
Persian so though so he got a lot of he
got a lot of Persian followers and stuff
like that he he does he speaks for farsy
and stuff so he he got a lot of Persian
people that follow him and stuff
Persians are dope he speaks fary on the
internet sometimes oh that's cool we
don't see a lot of that let's go
something man [__] goes oh gots his legs
together ah he's too
high oh damn oh [__] oh [__] oh nope
that was a bad idea now he's going to
take you down yeah oh he got him down
now oh that was a bad idea he looked at
his he looked at his corner like third
yeah Kobe has why not do this in the
first round Kobe you've given up two
rounds playing grabz it was made a
mistake
yeah he like looked like he almost had
it look like he was going to go for an
arm bar can get up from this it's going
to be tough with Kobe on top of you but
he's pretty good getting up oh oh he
got so fast Kobe in trouble now yeah oh
look at him shooting in look at him shoo
in what is going what that Kobe took
down Usman yeah Kobe's takedown is not
bad look he's going to take him down
look at this look at that look at that
he took down Usman and he took down Kobe
now that boy wrestle wow I'm impressed
yeah I'm impressed he's going for that
oh he got him how impressive is that got
taken down got up shot back in got him
down now he's about to kick him in the
face Kobe's in trouble that that takeown
was the ego thing yes that's that's all
it was all he was like oh really check
this out
Kobe's like damn I took him down he got
up then he took me down I'm now I got
his mind is [__] yep yeah that's he's
in a little bit of trouble now look he
got switch stances I I kick the other
leg when he he he's back kick that leg
the leg is back every time he kick that
leg he switch stance I don't see if Leon
wants to get a bunch of fans he should
knock Kobe out and then flip Trump
off and then be like Bradley stop eating
the mic Fu dude it's not that bad I'm
back away from it right yeah yeah hey
Leon flip off the the world's greatest
president I'mma stop being a fan of him
yeah yeah yeah I get
it Kobe's forced to if I told you Kobe's
forced a strike with Leon in the third
round there's no way you'd bet on Kobe
it's a
disaster who was favorite to bet on Leon
was pretty heavily favorite I mean
two-year layoff man Kid Rock Look so
Sad Kid Rock Kid Rock blew up the Bud
Light with a gun and then like week
later drinking Bud Light he's like yeah
it is what it is I don't follow Kid Rock
he does like cruise ships bro I one time
right after my fight with with
um Forest Griffin like shortly after
that uh I went home to Memphis and one
of my old old high school wrestling
buddies like yeah I got some Kid Rock um
concert tickets for you me and my cousin
went and I thought Kid Rock was still
kid rocks that type of rap stuff and I
went man country yeah and I me me and my
cousin only two black people there yeah
man that's a that you're in trumpville
it's like when I go to Monster Jam oh my
God bro I left I I left and one woman
said I never thought you would go down
you know with the southern accent in my
hometown I like what you talking about I
try to make a joke what you talking
about I don't go down she said oh yeah
you went down against Forest like Dam
[__] I didn't even go down he won by
decision the [__] you talking about I
said I'm out I'm out of here I'm sure
the Kid Rock concert attracts some weird
people that's like monster D it's just
like a warlock calling yeah I stopped
being a fan of him when I found out that
he's doing country like that's not my my
genre or something I love when he's like
my name is
kid kid
rock used to be fir was great didn't he
because he in Detroit right he came up
uh with I don't know where he he's from
Detroit I didn't know that I didn't know
where he's from has he why the ice
though what's that really gonna do the
ice it lowers your temperature I think
yeah ch calms you down that much yeah
yeah
yeah cuz from Michigan he's from
Michigan you yeah Detroit hipop you
haven't had that one fight yet have you
well you you should hey let's let's do
this let's do this let us handpick him
an opponent I'm down and we just put it
on YouTube live or something like
that he wants a he wants a bag though he
wants a bag wa what this is like amateur
like you don't get [__] for amateur get
the first fight some these YouTubers do
though that's what he wants where where
where he know how to make money from it
yeah you don't think we could you should
have you should have a warm-up
fight it's not as
cool want k for a whole bunch of people
ain't cool either yeah but if you're
going to do it you want to get paid if
you can get be you are R of
Millionaire's money everything exactly
that's the
point like why just do it then you need
be more like your brother right now man
okay man okay your brother would fight
somebody for no money and
van different circumstan bro you you you
the man you can make you can make money
fight somebody else that that never had
a fight before both of you guys make
money together I'm trying to think he'd
be good for him though somebody a
heavyweight has to be but they have to
be have like a big fall like he has a
like Bradley's pretty famous I know but
you can get somebody else that want to
try got a big following they never
fought before damn that was a good that
was a good shot I know is he going to
get out of it Leon oh is he have a
guilty he need to face him and get the
double under hooks now yep wait oh mind
oh look he has a front oh it's tight oh
it's tight oh bre his own neck he could
have broke his own neck [__] he could
have broke his he he's figh
nasty damn that was impressive that was
impressive W that was impressive he
could have broke his own neck God if
you're Kobe though it's like you've
tried everything man yeah like where do
you go from here I I wouldn't I wouldn't
be surprised if he retires tonight I
don't see him going down back in the
queue and trying to I mean even just in
this fight where do you go in the rest
of this fight like you couldn't take him
down I'd be relentless with the
takedowns because he's just G get look
at his body he's get picked apart stay
on the outside look at his leg look at
his body like he's getting eaten alive
how you get a tighter shot after two
years anyway two years well that's what
people are saying it's like he shouldn't
been here but you know it's a WWE UFC
mix he's chopping him down but this is
the fourth round though Leon should have
been chopping that leg a little bit more
though you try to hit him with the Jake
Paul
terrible gaml when you're forced to
strike with Leon Edwards especially
after you made fun of his dead dad awful
awful night for
kobby now he just looks stupid yeah now
he looks
ridiculous but I tell you what I would I
would take some of my hatred back if
Leon's dad was really like trafficking
and doing all that crazy stuff though
cor kby he was anded that's allegedly we
don't know either we need to we need to
you know there's no
facts was if they want to make this
fight exciting do uh in the middle of
the fight check in with Trump see what
he thinks of the fight
check what do you guys thinking who you
have winning how dope with that you got
all these celebrities there you got
Donald Trump trump what do you how's
Kobe looking things and pull it out what
do you like so far he's doing excellent
he's doing great he's doing excellent
you're like no he's not hey you think if
Trump get back an office will he still
come to the UFC fights yeah Dana are
close yeah yeah
but he got to have like a 100 Secret
Service with him and [__] like that he
has to have it now so you know how many
people want to kill anyway you get it
for like 20 years after you retire I
know you get it for life oh that's right
I think life
yeah and there's a bunch of I remember
when we played Tex andm President Bush
showed up when I was in college I was at
see we played at T&M I was like what is
all this Secret Service it was all for
President Bush there was n kit hey if
you was a secret servant for for Trump D
don't say servant
service service service servant is what
they are they are that's a secret
servant yeah
secret if you if he was a secret servant
for um for Trump trump would you take a
bullet for him oh that's my job so you
do that's my job yeah dog you got to do
it you kind of got to that's like saying
hooker like I'll do it but I don't suck
dicks like whoa whoa hey you in the why
you go there though you in the wrong
business girl I think I think hookers
they like sucking dick that's why they
in that job yeah they probably prefer
that than the whole get
down damn bro D his leg is tore up this
just damn man hey do you think you
finish that bag for the fifth round I'm
trying yeah I know you I'm trying to get
I know you are I know you
are damn he's he's man he's just Bing
him oh he's going be some trouble oh
made a mistake there oh got his back 45
seconds left though
what if he's whispering to Z about his
dad right now damn would that be messed
up oh yeah that'd be messed up I
know what could we have that Native
American tattoo on him though which one
the feather on
his he over oh
oh KOB takedown offense is filthy man
he's just made some errors in in the
transitions where he keeps ended up on
bottom it's strange Trump has no clue
what he's watching right now I mean not
a lot has
happened take a few take Downs what if
Dana tell the judges to get this fight
to covid so Donald Trump can get in
there no well I heard Trump wanted to
walk uh Kobe out but Daniel was like
uhuh why I don't know how you hearing
all this stuff yeah who where you hear
that from I hang out certain water
coolers man water cooler around water
you Dana still cool huh yeah I'm cool
with him you text you don't text you
texting cool no I don't think he likes
me but I'm cool with him oh okay I don't
know I have nothing have you ever asked
him to be on on your podcast
never never I I asked my manager to ask
him once a
week I'm surprised he wouldn't come on
yours do you guys have a good
relationship I don't think so
why we we stopped having a good
relationship when I did the 18
movie because you wanted to do the movie
and he wanted you to fight yeah that
just my luck the movie came right when I
was supposed to fight Rashard I've been
working on that movie for at that time
probably like five years and but you got
understand Dana as a businessman's like
no dog like you you got a contract
obligation you decide to do this fight
yeah you're a fighter you're a movie
star you know what saying he needs to
play ball cuz it's like all right well
if I do this movie I get more famous
sells more pay-per-views for you so you
make more money if you just give me this
time right he wasn't but he doesn't it's
his way of the highway yeah what what
saved me is I didn't sign a bout
agreement oh type move yeah he signed
that bout agreement it just I I I didn't
sign I didn't it was just it just
happened the battle agreement wasn't
there yet oh good for you
so it went the relationship went South
after that yeah the relationship went
South mine went South when I started
talking [__] about the rebok deal I'm
glad you talk the [__] about that re
rebok [__] me over too so yeah me too
I'm the one that brought that deal and
they just everything I didn't make a one
red Cent yeah I went hard in the pain on
it Dana should have just Dana should
have gave me some of that money though
he should gave me something just smooth
things over yeah me too he just hijacked
my whole sponsor yeah me too all my
stuff yeah you cost a lot of money
cuz yeah I'm glad it happened though it
forced me to get into podcast and
standup so he actually help me out I I
have no ill will towards him at
all which which was you say your stand
up is better in the cage or on the
stage oh good question I like the way
you phrase that yeah me too man you're a
poet dog definitely on
stage I've been doing standup comy as
long as long as I've been doing Punch or
now almost nine years
I I want to do it but I don't have the
balls to you so good at it get over
that it take a lot of balls to stand in
front of people and try to make them
land yeah that's tough
man I ra go in some tight ass shorts and
get my ass kicking front of millions of
people not me [__]
that you know I saw I went to Laugh
Factory I saw Chris D he so a surpris
guest Chris a monster he was so it was
so weird how you could see how the room
just throw some punches before him some
people after when he went out
wrestling theg nuts thr some punches
what czy he he he want to submit him
no that be nuts if you if you bet uh
Leon Edwards via submission yeah you can
bet that like how yeah yeah on
DraftKings using prom coach one you with
DraftKings yep they take good care of
you yep tell them about your black for
years tell them about your black friend
I'm sure they'd be down for your pod
could you you do the Pod with who with
um bear I've never met him I've heard
good things though I was telling you
that I heard good things about him he's
a good dude bro my buddy what's up with
some chains dog all right I like chains
you like chains yeah man all right we
hook you up thanks
D damn what's he got a he oh he has a
triangle oh now he an AR and there's a
lot of time left oh he got out of
it what's more likely Leon finishes with
a triangle or Bradley finish is that bag
of chips
uh your lips are
red Bradley for sure I ain't going to
finish the chips to be honest are you
going to fast tomorrow now you ate all
this no I'm eat some more tonight hell
yeah do you ever fast yeah every day how
many hours um I normally eat around like
2 2:30 3:00 I stop eating around like 10
o00 I fast from 7 to 2:00 p.m. 700 p.m.
to 2: p.m. yeah 10 to 3: I do it so I
don't eat breakfast I don't eat the so I
quit I eat dinner at 7:00 yeah and then
I don't eat again till 2:00 p.m. oh okay
the next day oh that's good 10 to three
fasting works man yeah that's why I got
my whole life yeah you've been doing
your whole life my whole life yeah it
ages you backwards
too yeah you do look younger yeah man
yeah you look I mean you lost some
weight too but you look a lot better
than last time oh [__] yeah I was I was
bad in that thank yeah yeah last time
you were sweating and [__] huh you were
sweating yeah you were sweating
like you had one you know on coming like
right here man chin you going let you
going to let them keep doing me like
this well Chin's a bonified alcoholic
don't look at him chin be drinking all
the time all day yeah damn chin got
liver problems Fu we'll do a show at
9:00 a.m. I'm like chin have you had a
whiskey already he's like yep [__] it I
used to be right there with him and then
I got my together that was one of my
favorite times you and me you yeah me
and you were drinking buddies man that's
a problem it is you going to stop of
course
you think you are going to stop Jin yeah
when well so I got my blood test back
and it's it's fine so I started drinking
more because my blood says is fine chin
sounds like a real attic right that's
crazy
yeah has it affected your life at all
Chen I mean what do you think yeah I'm
I'm I'm just trying to guide you to the
light here it's like it's like grandage
is trying to guide me into Flat Earth I
ain't trying to guide you into Flat
Earth but you're show me the ways that's
what I'm doing with you I just tell you
what I believed in I know and I dig it
I'm not trying I'm a listening I'm like
it I'm not trying to push that on
anybody like people can believe in
whatever they want to emergency Landings
yeah I'm going look that up tonight so
he's on top right now he's he just doing
work yeah he won one round maybe cuz the
I guess if he ends it might they'll give
him this round but the majority of the
fight like Leon was doing really well
early in this round so I guess you give
it to
him like why all that now why you why
come on KOB put oh that's the fight
that's the fight I know Kobe definitely
didn't win that fight he said give me
the belt that's definitely not happen he
lost four to one yeah not the best fight
he got a little better at the end there
but Kobe was gave up three rounds